>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, D.C.
>> Anne Cecelia Holmes:
It is an honor
to introduce this evening's
reader, Sandra Beasley.
Sandra is the author of
three poetry collections,
most recently Count the Waves,
along with I was a Jukebox,
winner of the Barnard Women Poet's
prize, and Theories of falling,
winner of the New Issues
Poetry Prize.
Honors for her work include a
2015 NEA Literature Fellowship,
the Center for Book
Arts Chapbook Prize,
and two DCCAH Artist Fellowships.
She lives right here, in Washington,
D.C. and is on the faculty
of the Low-Residency MFA program
at the University of Tampa.
I want to talk just a bit
about Sandra Beasley's most recent
collection, Count the Waves.
In it, poems create and examine
correspondence over distances,
how the weariness of
travel can code and twist
and pull at our relationships.
It's like participating in a game
of telephone, but often lonelier.
The end of the receiving line never
gets to meet the original voice,
or the connection is lost,
or the preceding participants
have all simply left,
leaving reliability up for question.
This is when Beasley's poems wildly
and inventively re-imagine
and retell history.
They look around and take inventory
of what deserves consideration
and what doesn't.
She uses humor in tandem with
vulnerability to play out the ways
in which intimacy can be
both elevated and flattened,
as in when I say I wish
to correspond with you,
what I mean is I want to bite your
tongue across these many miles.
Lines like this startle
us, make us laugh,
and ultimately reshape
our sense of the truth.
Please join me in welcoming
Sandra Beasley.
[ Applause ]
>> Sandra Beasley:
Good early evening.
At the end of the festivities
last night, there was a reception
at the Library of Congress, and
my husband said it's really fun
to see you in your element.
And I said, well what
does that mean?
And he said, you know,
you went whoo a lot.
And I did.
This is an occasion for going whoo.
We're celebrating such a great time
for literature in this country.
We're celebrating the
leadership of Carla Hayden,
we're celebrating a whole bunch
of people being in the house today
and just giving fantastic
presentations.
And I personally am celebrating
the gratitude I have for those
in the room right this moment.
I see friends, I see
students, I see fellow writers.
And in particular, this opportunity
that was given to me by the Library
of Congress and the NEA, so Amy,
Amy's incredible staff, Rob, Karen,
my handler for the day, who
made sure no one stole my purse.
The staff at today's signing,
and great people in the house,
and my husband, Chance,
he's hiding out there.
All right.
I really appreciated that
introduction to Count the Waves,
and so I'm going to jump right
into reading from this series,
and then we'll actually
hear a few new poems,
and then we'll open
it up for questions.
I went through a period of
my life of about five years
when I was traveling relentlessly.
I put about 50,000
plus miles on my car.
And so in some ways, Count
the Waves is about the way
that intimacy is both lost and,
in some ways gained,
over long distances.
We allow ourselves to say things
that perhaps we would not otherwise.
And when I was going through
that period of my life,
many people mentioned that the
practical thing would be for me
to move my things into
a storage unit,
accept this nomadic time,
and I couldn't do it.
I could not give up the foot that
was keeping me in Washington,
D.C. So when I read this
opening poem from the collection,
which is called Inner Flamingo,
I want you to understand
that while birds are often
appearing in metaphors in my work,
these are literal flamingos,
these are National Zoo flamingos,
these are me getting home maybe
once a month, twice a month,
and the first thing I did
on a pretty day was walking
down to the National Zoo,
taking in the open air aviary,
having quality peacock time,
checking on those teenager cheetahs,
right, and looking at those
flamingos and thinking,
what love can I find that anchors me
here the way I want to be anchored?
And I did.
Inner Flamingo.
At night my body discovers
her secret geometries,
inner-flamingo knee hitch,
inner-flamenco arm arch,
Hermes' diagonal of
flight across the mattress.
The sleeping body is selfish.
The sleeping body cannot lie.
Once there was the man from
whom I always woke huddled
at the bed's edge.
Then there was a man
who laid his lust
as a doorknocker at
the small of my back.
The first time I laid down
with you, sweat-stuck,
each onion-ed in the
skin of the other,
I assumed the unconscious
hours would peel us free.
Yet when sun cracked its eye over
the horizon, we were as we'd been.
And the pink of me cocked
her head, listening.
As you might imagine in a
collection that chooses to start
out with a poem of lasting love,
if I tell you that I traveled
relentlessly for 5 years
and 50,000 miles, you might guess
that there was some non
lasting love prior to that.
And so I'm going to read a
trio of poems that describe
that through line that you
can locate in this book.
Fidelity II.
[ Laughter ]
In some version, his pericardium was
pierced, the body bleeding water.
Some say only the usual red.
In one story, a full moon,
in another, hours of eclipse.
Where gospels agree is
at the door of the cave
when a boulder rolls back and
some woman, one Mary or another,
names that first essential absence.
It is April and he raises
his fears every three days.
He brings home a bouquet
of muscular lilies.
He waits for the miracle.
She calls her name into a cave and
the cave answers with her name.
In the conversation in
the signing line earlier,
a young gentleman was kind enough to
come up and ask how a poem worked,
something about my process.
And I talked about oysters
and how, if you know anything
about the actual anatomy of
real oysters, this little bit
of irritant grit gets
into the creature.
And for me, that might be an
image, or a phrase, or a question.
And what natural oyster will do is
it'll try to protect itself from it,
so it coats itself, coats that
grit in juice and coats again,
each layer hardening,
each time, realizing oh,
I still have not gotten that thing
out of my body, coating it again,
coating it again, until
the pearl is formed.
And what I was trying to
communicate is that a lot of times,
by the time I sit down
to draft the poem,
I've been working on
the poem for days.
And if I'm lucky, it's one of those
perfect pearls, but usually it's
like a freshwater pearl, kind of
murky and misshapen, and, you know.
But that metaphor of an
oyster, that one stays with me.
Parable. Worries come
to a man and a woman,
small ones, light in the hand.
The man decides to
swallow his worries,
hiding them deep and within himself.
The woman throws hers as far
as she can from the porch.
They touch each other, relieved.
They make coffee and make
plans for the seaside in May,
all the while the worries of the man
take his insides as their oyster,
coating themselves in juice,
first gastric, then nacreous,
growing layer upon layer.
And in the fields beyond
the wash line,
the worries of the woman take root,
stretching tendrils
through the rich soil.
The parable tells us,
consider the ravens.
But the ravens caw useless
from the gutters of this house.
The parable tells us consider
the lilies, but they shiver
in the side yard, silent.
What the parable does
not tell you is
that this woman collects
porcelain cats.
Some big, some small,
some gilded, some plain.
One cat stops doors, another
cups cream, another sugar.
This man knows they are tacky.
Still when the one that had belonged
to her great aunt fell and broke,
he held her as she
wept, held her even
after her breath had
lengthened to sleep.
The parable does not
care about such things.
Worry has come to the
house of a man and a woman.
Their garden yields, greens
gone, corn cowering in its husk,
he asks himself what will we eat?
They sit at the table and
open the mail, a bill,
a bill, a bill, an invitation.
She turns a salt shaker
cat between her palms
and asks, but what will we wear?
He rubs her wrist with his thumb,
he wonders how to offer the string
of pearls now writhing in his belly.
Fidelity I.
She did not mean to keep the
whisk when she packed the kitchen
of the apartment they once lived in.
Night after night, he tried to
emulsify soy sauce and peanut butter
with a fork, before dumping
the tan brown mess on lettuce
and chicken breast boiled to lumps,
good fat bubbling off to pool
in the hollow of the burner.
The whisk was an honest gift,
curly cued and white ridged ribbon
from a woman who trusted
overpriced solutions,
to a man who thought
anything could blend
if he worked his hand hard enough.
So in addition to that
narrative, there's another sequence
that threads through
Count the Waves.
And I wanted to read poems
from it, because I think
that this was the work
that the National Endowment
for the Arts was kind
enough to reward,
to recognize with a
fellowship, which really,
quite literally, shored up my life.
It came at a moment when
I needed the support,
I needed the encouragement.
And I continued on this
strange path of trying
to make a living as a writer.
In 1853, now this is real,
a write named A.C. Baldwin
published a compendium of phrases,
and he referenced them by number.
It was this code for
conversations over long distances.
He called this, this collection,
The Traveler's Vade Mecum.
Or, instantaneous letter
writer by mail or telegraph
for the convenience of
persons traveling on business
or for pleasure and for others
whereby a vast amount of time,
labor and trouble is saved.
So in a collection that was already
destined to be about long distances,
I combed through this
manuscript, in part inspired
by an outside solicitation.
There will be a whole anthology
of Traveler's Vade Mecum
poems out later this fall.
And I picked the ones
that resonated for me.
So you'll hear, for each
title, an actual line
from the 1853 Traveler's Vade Mecum.
And then under that, thinking
about this idea of space,
of intimacy lost and gained.
The Traveler's Vade
Mecum line 7,671.
It is no secret here.
Dirt, wrote a British
anthropologist,
is matter out of place.
Drop a grape from bowl to
table and we call it dirty.
Drop a grape to the
floor and it is trash.
Bowl, table, these
are ordering agents,
ways to tell the functional
from fallen.
Skin, tendon, thee
are ordering agents.
You want to kiss my mouth, but
not the teeth inside my mouth.
You want to hold my hand, but
not the blood within that hand.
There is a truth in you, but
it won't be the dirty truth
until it tumbles into
the air between us.
In this city, there is always
a long walk home at 7 AM light,
high heels stabbing
the subway grates,
a walk home past gutters
littered with the non sequitur
of chicken bones, wings that
once held a dream of flight.
Anybody ever had a person in
your life, and this happens to be
about a he, but it's not
gendered, who just consumed,
like kind of locust like, whether
it be emotionally or in terms
of the cupboard, or just
kind of never kept track
of the available resources
and just assumed
that something would always
come up to fill the pot?
If you've ever encountered
someone like this on your travels,
you usually end up
writing a poem about them.
The Traveler's Vade
Mecum line 1,181.
The calamity is not serious.
He catches the rain
in his cooking pot.
There's nothing to put
He places a stone in
the cooking pot.
He dances by the fire
as the water boils.
Stone soup, stone soup, he
sings, lend a little garnish,
he tells our village, soon
you'll each have a bowl.
In go the carrot tops, the rosemary,
in goes the ham bone
with lard at lips.
The children gather,
the strays mewls.
Sometimes it has to be button soup,
sometimes ax soup, sometimes nail.
In France, he is a soldier.
In Portugal, he is a monk
stirring sopa de pedra.
Wherever he goes he
is the clever man.
Folktale 1548 in the
Aarne-Thompson index.
Not to be confused with his
brothers, Eulenspiegel 1635,
Master Thief 1525, or 1574,
the flattering foreman.
He'll never have a turn as the
stupid man, the man looking
for a wife, or the man who
kills slash injures ogre.
His is not the cat as helper 545 B.
He will never be the lucky accident.
He wakes each day with an empty pot
and the spoon his grandmother
gave him.
Stone soup, stone soup, he sings.
The heel on his left boot
loosens, so he dances harder.
Our village is his pantry.
His is the recipe that
needs no knife.
I'll just read one
more from this series.
So I had to really think
through the reality of 1853,
because some phrases you might
take on one surface level meaning
for the contemporary day,
only to think it through
and realize people were
approaching these words differently.
In The Traveler's Vade Mecum, line
4,234 declares, flour is firm,
which is thinking in
terms of stocks,
of commodities, but
I thought, flour?
And I returned myself to thinking
what was being eaten in those days,
what was being carried
by those, perhaps,
readying for service
on the battlefield.
Flour is firm.
Baking two parts flour to one
part water could stop a bullet.
So good soldiers carries their
hard tack over their hearts.
Break it down with a
rifle butt, flood it,
fry it in pig fat to
make hell fire stew.
Gnaw it raw and praise the juice.
Does wheat prepare
for this as it grows,
seeking the light in
a half thawed field?
Do stalks know their strength
is merely in their number?
What is ground down we name flour in
promise that it will be made useful,
otherwise, it's just dust.
Sheet iron crackers, teeth
dullers, would you call it starving,
if a man dies with hard tack
still tucked in his vest?
Can you call it food,
if the bullet comes only
at the moment he gives
in and swallows?
I thought I wanted to
read some new poems.
I might never get to read at the
National Book Festival again.
I should go ahead and break it out.
And I know that, as
well as this being a day
for readers, it's a day for writers.
And I'm just not talking
about the people on stage.
I know there's a lot of
people in this room right now
who are drafting, who are
working, who are revising,
and you're up here with me.
How many people here actually
live in the D.C. area?
Sweet. That's going to be my
official Tweet for my presentations,
sweet, that's Sandra Beasley.
I want to read a sestina.
You don't have to know that form.
I mention it so that if you
hear a repetition of words,
it's not your imagination.
The acrobatics of a sestina are that
you commit to a set of six end words
and then you have to use
them in a particular pattern.
And this is a D.C. sestina.
It's called, American Rome.
The dedication line recognizes
Marion Shepilov Barry,
JR, 1936 to 2014.
Marion Barry, jams
of Washington state,
I thought they were
mocking our city.
Take a mayor and boil his sugar
down, spoon spreadable, sweet.
We take presidents and run them
in a game's fourth inning stretch.
We bullets and turn
them to sea dogs.
Do you remember that ballot?
Sea dogs, dragons,
stallions, express?
The Washington Wizards was
no more or less of a stretch.
We waved gavels like
wands in this city.
We're the small town in which the
president can plant some roses.
Each time I sit down to say goodbye,
all I ever write down is Dear City.
My neighbor walks his
dogs past a monument
to a president's terrier,
forever bronzed.
Washington has no J Street,
no Z, yet the city maps attend
to fifty states and a
stretch of five blocks.
Northeast Metro track, a
stretch named Puerto Rico Avenue.
Bow down to the un-mapped
names, Chocolate City, Simple,
Ben Ali served up, chili dogs
served up through a riot,
and Walter Washington was the first
and last time a president
picked our mayor.
The truth is, presidents
come and go,
four or eight years at a stretch.
Barry said, I'm yours
for life, Washington.
Emperor Marion, who could
get down with Chuck Brown.
Later, reporters will dog, his
bitch set me up, his graft.
Dear City, will you let
me claim you as my city?
To love you is to defy precedent.
Your quadrants hustle like a pack
of dogs around the hydrant capitol.
They stretch and paw, they
yap and will not settle down.
Traffic, the berry
to Washington's jam.
For city miles, Barry's
motorcade stretched.
We laid him among vice
presidents, down where dogs play,
by the banks of Washington.
I want to thank the folks, thanks.
[ Applause ]
I just want to acknowledge and thank
the fact that we have translators
and cued speech professionals
up here.
It's, I imagine to do that
on the fly is difficult
for anyone, but poets are crazy.
You never know what word's
going to come out of our mouth.
So I really appreciate
the initiative
to make this event inclusive
for everyone, and your work.
[ Applause ]
Sestinas are, I can give
myself over to a sestina
and kind of make it work.
Sonnets very rarely happen for me
unless I literally happen to notice
that the poem is already
taking the form of a sonnet.
I promised that I would read
the poem that I just wrote,
which is a sonnet that, well,
I didn't know it was a sonnet.
It was something that I started
to draft two days ago
and wrote yesterday.
This is inspired by childhood
memories of buying what,
at the time, seemed like really fun
toys, and in hindsight were kind
of peculiar creatures help captive.
I'm referred to what you sometimes
see labeled Mexican jumping beans.
North of the border, we're
labeled Papa Pedro's Jumping Beans.
Past the magnets, next
to the fat fried snacks,
in plastic boxes of
red, white or green.
Each bean 1.99 plus tax.
We jump against light
and jump against heat,
inner larva wrenching
toward cooler places,
thinking we're on a Sinaloa peak.
Still in the Sebastiana's
embraces, our cocoon dies,
know nothing of this land.
We are no one's toy.
We ready to fly.
Perhaps these are the
pods Jack took in hand
so his beanstalk could
breach the gold coined sky.
A child can dream, but
child you are lying.
We're bought and sold
for our style of dying.
I'm going to finish
with a couple of poems.
One is from an anthology that
is called Still Life with Poem.
I think a lot of people
don't realize,
the editors that put their
time and their effort,
nobody's getting paid for these.
We do these for the love of
coming together in collaboration.
I think the economy of
poetry is a gift economy.
This is a beautiful collection
of poems that were written to,
in response to or to create
still lives on the page.
I live with a painter, so I
often think of still lives
or figurative landscapes
exactly of the kind
that he assures me are
not present in his work.
You'll notice with the title,
I'm claiming that, well,
title's Still Life with Sex.
Truth is, almost all still
lives have sex in them.
Anytime you see fruit, any time you
see a fly, all the Flemish masters,
they're all talking about death.
Still life with sex, July 2015,
but first a skull grinning
amongst the grapes.
But first, hydrangea moons
barely risen, cratering.
But first milky balls
congregating in the sink.
But first, sticky spoons
congregating in the bowls.
But first that vegetal smell.
But first that clank of
pipes filling with air again.
But first dirt spilling
on your side of the couch.
from your Monday shoes.
But first a canteen of water.
But first five loggers.
But first, Magnum P.I.
is on. But first, Tom Selleck is on.
But first, kiss me because
you clutter the pewter.
But first, kiss me because you
track in the necessary dirt.
You see a violin, an ad, prosciutto.
The cat's back is bleeding, again.
We are trying to make
a space a hold it open.
The skull, grinning
amongst grapes grins at us.
Those globes of hydrangea
were once bright as June.
[ Applause ]
Yay for new work.
Even though it scares
the bejesus out of me
to read it in front of you all.
I'll just finish with a
poem from Count the Waves.
One of my favorite things
about poetry is the conversation
it creates, often with people
who sometimes the first
thing they say is, you know,
I'm not really sure I love poetry.
But, I've had conversations
about capybara's,
conversations about the
obscure language of [inaudible],
and thanks to this poem, a lot
of conversations about ukulele's.
Ukulele. The vessel is
simple, a rowboat among yachts.
No one hides a Tommy
gun in its case.
No blues man runs over
his uke in a whiskey rage.
The last of the Hawaiian
queens translated the name gift
that came here, while Portuguese
historians translate jumping flea
the way a player's
fingers pick and fly.
If you have a cigar box, it'll do.
If you have fishing
line, it'll sing.
If there is to be one instrument
of love, not love vanished
or imagined, but love,
it's this one.
Fit a melody in the crook
of your arm and strum.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
So I was asked to leave a
few moments for questions
if anybody wants to inquire.
We have two microphones
that you can queue up to.
And if nobody has any questions,
I'll just read a couple
of more poems, so.
I know, poetry, usually
poetry both begins and ends
with a strange moment
of questioning,
often when you get a moment like
so what do you write poems about?
And I always find myself
wanting to say, ukulele's
and prosciutto and skulls.
Hello.
>> Hello. You mentioned living with
a painter, I'm wondering, I write
and my father painted,
and I've always felt
like there's a relationship
between poetry and painting,
so I'm curious how that
manifests itself in your house.
>> Sandra Beasley: Well, my
mother is also a visual artist,
so I truly grew up surrounded by the
modes and the active work process.
You know, my husband and I can
go to an art museum and walk
through a gallery, and we can
love the exact same six paintings
and we can love them for
totally different reasons, right?
I find myself reaching for
narrative, and he is able
to sometimes recognize what to me
is a very subtle level of craft.
And similarly, when he's
commenting on a poem
or a literature it's probably more
easily, it's probably more easy
for him to respond to
the theme or the subject,
where as I might be saying
goodness, that's a sestina, right?
So I think that they are,
they're dove tailing disciplines
that allow us to each enrich and
illuminate the others process.
People sometimes ask
if we collaborate.
We collaborate on cooking,
we do that really well.
I stay out of his studio.
But one thing I will just
finish by saying is I love being
around artists because they're
messy, so even when I'm complaining
about it, I kind of admire it.
When you go to an art colony,
you can always tell the artists
who've put in a firm day's work
because they are just,
they're just dirty.
Writers might, I've been known
to wear my skirts, my nice shoes,
you know, I admire that giving
oneself over to the process.
Yeah. Hello.
>> Hey, I know you.
>> Sandra Beasley: You do.
>> I was wondering what
sparks you poetry, usually,
if there's a pattern with that?
If it comes about with a feeling
or if it comes about with an image
that you see, or with something
that you see in a literary work?
>> Sandra Beasley: Yeah.
Yeah. I absolutely, it changes.
I go through different periods.
So for example, when I found
the Traveler's Vade Mecum,
that allowed me to really sink in
and kind of work through a project
where I was thinking
about this particular time
and these spaces, this
mode of traveling.
In I Was the Jukebox,
I have a whole series
of poems that are speaks poems.
I wanted to inhabit
bodies outside my own.
And usually my access point for
getting the poems started was
to really research the anatomy
of a platypus, or a capybara,
or the nature of orcas,
which are really curious.
And then that would give
me the grist I needed
to step into that life.
So I do, I get, I get, I get
attached, I never thought of myself
as a project person
and I absolutely am.
I will, I'm noticing some folks
slipping in, and I always,
as a matter of good forum, want
to make sure they hear a poem
when they show up to
a poetry reading,
so I'll just read one other
poem that is, answers,
speaks to that question because
it is the series that I'm working
through now, which, among other
things, I'm situating the speaker
at memorials and monuments.
And I'm having the speaker speak to
their understanding of those people.
Siri wants in on the poetry reading.
I'm having people speak
to the larger context
of knowledge that we have.
[ Laughter ]
Seriously, Siri like
spontaneously started up.
I've been using it as my clock.
So the idea is, what would a D.C.
person or someone really couched
in American history and the
ambiguities and the complexities
that surround these figures
who inspire memorials,
what would they think?
And I'm working on a whole
series of poems this way.
So this one is titled,
Jefferson, Midnight.
One of my favorite things about
the memorials is that you can go
at any time of day, so
you can go at midnight.
And for some years now, I've
been finding ways to do that.
Jefferson, midnight.
In another version of this story,
he's a naturalist who
dabbled in politics.
He reinvented the plow, he joined
the American Philosophical Society's
bone committee.
And while trying to prove
the great western lion,
gave us our first giant sloth.
He shipped a rotting moose to France
to demonstrate the
greatness of our mammals.
He is a father of paleontology
who didn't believe extinction
was part of God's plan.
He asked Louis and Clark,
should they encounter the
mammoth, to capture one for him.
For months, his sea
wall has been sinking,
the Potomac's mud flaps
sucking at the support timbers.
In 1918 and then for
six months after,
the tidal basin was chlorinated
so that this bank could
become a beach, white's only.
Those drawn to rising heat
heavily populate the ceiling
of Jefferson's Memorial.
Once the sun sets, the temperature
drops, they lose their grip
and fall, bodies bounce off my
shoulders, bodies land in my hair,
guards call this the spider rain.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
I no longer have track of
the time because Siri can,
is not, oh, 5 minutes left.
And thank you to the woman
keeping us all on time.
Are there any other questions?
Anybody? Yes?
>> What do you read in your?
>> Sandra Beasley: I'll
repeat the question.
>> Spare time?
>> Sandra Beasley: What do
I read in my spare time?
So I actually, you might have sensed
from some of the poems I have read,
I also work in non fiction, and,
in fact, right now I'm working
on a collection of
creative non fiction.
So I don't know if I would
characterize it as spare time,
but the other part of my
attention is to seek out memoirs,
to seek out kind of
experimental or essay collections.
I love reading non fiction.
I love reading about the
science and the texture
of the world around us, right?
So that's it.
And plus, I, sometimes when
people act as if arts and stem,
so to speak, have to be on opposite
sides, I try to remind them I went
to a high school for
science and technology.
Like, they trusted me with the key
to a helium neon laser
at some point.
So, you know, I think that
anything that feeds that part
of my intellect, I'm thrilled
to kind of nourish it.
Yeah. There's another, we
have two more questions,
and I think I'll be able
to get to them both.
Yeah.
[ Inaudible ]
>> Sandra Beasley: Do I still
have my extreme food allergies?
So, both in my first
collection, Theories of Falling,
and in a memoir I published called,
Don't Kill the Birthday Girl,
Tales From an Allergic
Life, I deal with the fact
that I have an incredible and
aggressive and severe range
of allergies, including milk, eggs,
beef, shrimp, cucumbers, cashews,
macadamia, yeah, they're
all at work.
I still write about food allergies.
It's an important part, when I
see the opportunity to advocate
for more sensitivity and
more awareness, I do.
[ Inaudible ]
The odds of, the question
is, could I outgrow them?
The odds of me outgrowing
them at this point in my life,
there are several critical
moments where bodies change,
and we associate that
with changes in allergies.
It can happen during pregnancy.
It can happen as a normal
growth phase at 5, at 13,
at 20, I'm past all of those.
So, you know, I'm okay with that.
I think that having the
allergies that I do has had costs,
but it's also made me an incredibly
aware presence in the world.
And for all I know, I
wouldn't be the poet
that I am if I didn't have it.
So, you know, you take
the whole package.
And the whole package includes
the Epi Pen that I've got
in my purse at all times.
We have one more question?
>> Yeah, who are some
of your favorite poets
and influences [inaudible]?
>> Sandra Beasley: Yeah, so when
there, if you, I'm hesitating
because what I try to be honest
about is that there was a time when,
if you asked me that, I felt
like I had to answer people
who were just canonically
appreciated,
and I'll tell you the
four poets, the five poets
who really made me love to
write when I was younger.
And that would be Langston Hughes,
Gwendolyn Brooks, E.E. Cummings,
Sylvia Plath, Sandra Cisneros.
Yeah. And they are, they are great,
great authors who I continue to,
if you love an author and you're
in the option to either mentor
or to teach, teach their work.
Don't teach who the canon is
telling you you need to be teaching.
Teach the people who you
feel passionate about,
who maybe you want to write.
That's how we change the canon.
[ Applause ]
So they were the ones I loved.
Yeah. We have two minutes left.
Any other questions?
Yeah.
[ Inaudible ]
Yeah. Okay, there's a request to
come to the microphone if possible?
>> What do you want your
legacy to be as a poet?
>> Sandra Beasley: What do I
want my legacy to be as a poet?
I think that there is an
unfortunate and false dichotomy
that has been created where people
feel like oh, I'm a formal poet,
or oh, I don't write with
form, I don't do that.
I don't know how that came about.
Every poem has form.
Every poem has rigor.
Every poem is making
decisions on the page.
Otherwise, you're talking about
some strange word splooge thing
that I'm not, probably,
going to be drawn into.
Yeah. I don't know how you signified
that word, but that's okay.
[ Laughter ]
What I'd like to be know as is
a poet who can have a collection
where a sestina and a
sonnet and a free verse poem
and a prose poem sit side by
side, and what you're thinking
about is the themes and the
concerns and the poetry.
And you're not thinking about
which camp I align with,
which conference I go to, which
buddies helped me get in what place.
I want to be known for the work.
And that, to me, involves a
kind of relentless formal,
because rigorous curiosity, not only
about what I choose to write about,
but how I shape it on the page.
>> Great. Thanks.
>> Sandra Beasley:
Thank you, so much.
All right.
[ Applause ]
I'm honored by this time.
Thank you all, and
have a great evening.
Thanks, again, to the National
Endowment for the Arts,
Library of Congress and all
of our sponsoring groups.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us as LOC.gov..